okay okay join join the Cooper I click
this woman oh my god that ball is so
realistic starting in 3 2 1 go
oh yeah I'm looking for my son there you
are my beautiful child yeah beautiful
Jay except on the darkest period doing
so cute oh god I got it made a bet baby
proof decision
oh god he's crazy look at my creepy
little fish arms you are so great come
here daddy oh my sweet child your chest
ha ha my sweet chalica here that I am
nah I stepped over you I'm sorry yeah if
you look down your face like goes into
your chest and your knees are already in
your chest and I - hey who's your daddy
I am your daddy you look so I like how
your eyeballs is popping out of your
face yes or yours okay what am i doing
I'm gonna kill myself
you're trying to kill yourself I'm
trying to make sure that you don't kill
yourself
okay I'm such a slow baby maybe I need
to distract where did you go what is it
don't go I'm trying oh god don't cry
don't creep after me
hey baby prove the place okay I made me
daddy
I'm not I can try to save you from
yourself all these sites are locked
except eyes were so hard as a baby I
must kill myself what if I just help you
kill yourself that really kind of
Awesome let's this is I don't even go in
over there I can't move very fast you're
so creepy horror game hello daddy oh
wait this way head move if I look up and
down no it doesn't but it man yeah do
that do that with your body ha ha you
spin me right round daddy right wrap in
me daddy okay jump into the ceiling
friend
bounce on the bed wait where's the
ceiling fan on the ceiling huh who else
would it be closed or try it I'm a beast
damn your socket I can't get up oh
there's a there's a strange object here
which is Oh God oh this is very it's
very inappropriate you put down the
stranger over object can I pick it up
please tell me the baby can pick it up
no I can't I guess
I thought it really really not a D
please please now hello daddy
come I come my child where'd you baby he
learned how to crawl Filan Italy yay I'm
so happy
okay I think upstairs is boring you're
right I'll let you see all the paintings
dancing and stuff
the paintings okay that's this my screen
then you went apart
yeah you know Wow
Bravo to me I am the best little baby
now play the piano to me Jesus all this
the cutest thing Oh No
hey high praise I'm notes are baby oh
wait can I stand on it and then you lift
it damn it
whoa whoa whoa but I worked okay where's
the kitchen
status come on your set up daddy wins oh
oh oh daddy wait daddy wins rematch hey
I found bleach no no no daddy won don't
drink the bleach you're a completely no
no this game is clearly flawless ten out
of ten ten out of ten
IGN best IGN out of ten IMDB Oscar
Rotten Tomatoes hey my sweet chatter
again hey I'm a win this crisis no no no
no I'm a win okay I don't win now how do
I baby first stuff I don't know block
this no need to block this door
no laughing inside I think you actually
have to click on things
no me ain't now I drink the day you
struck me I gotta so much bleach oh god
you're all white now that's weird
okay am I gonna go eat batteries no not
the batteries my mom's gonna be super
pissed shut up - here have some fruit
have a banana banana you love bananas
see please have the banana yeah bet oh
god the game is losing all color Oh God
battery oh that the batteries how do you
even I am a strong baby ah I'm out the
back
what do you got yo he got at the back
more bleach are you gonna fork I got a 4
stopping me let go of the four come to
me well no leather gave me the four come
here daddy
okay stab you with a fork oh god there's
an electrical cabinet there I got a pro
Timmy
no no Oh knife right myself is a baby
Jesus mom say be really pissed now
rematch so mad when I come home okay I'm
the human now oh really I think no
you're not but I know how to baby-proof
this place baby no let me start I get
out of my crib yeah okay have you do
don't go inside the oven I'm going
inside the oven there's just a big
floating by the door where what are you
doing and [ __ ] no no no no no you were
the battery Nana Hate About You desktop
etiquette I mean trash I'm so
structuring I go under the table I don't
know how to stop this baby this baby is
clearly out of control in to do don't go
inside the oven there I'm cooking a
banana I'm cooking a banana connect oh
yay
cook the baby okay wait I can turn off
the heat hello okay secondly it's too
hard is a baby
I turned the second off not it let me
okay [ __ ] this I'm out Amala I'm gonna
taking the baby I'm good how do you look
at my face find out ways to kill me
quicker okay I will I will kill your son
my sweet child my sweet baby my sweet
sweet baby oh man I can't go outside and
run it right what if you go inside the
fridge what have you join me in the
fridge
what's beeping it's the microwave do you
want to go in and see if it's good no I
want to go into fridge okay there you go
close the first reached close oh it's
nice in here nice and cool nice and cool
a diversity oven it's super nice your
trash will be into trash oh I want to go
into trash you are going to trash going
I want to go twice you are going to
trash a you go ahead trash yeah that's
right
that looks really nice hey I can close
it I need to get Michael said hahaha
now we're gonna roll Tammy down this
stairs then we're gonna row - hey you
book oh I came outside no you're still
in it it's definitely I'm walking on it
like a barrel I'm outside the trash
right now
no you're inside what's going on ah whoa
whoa what is HAP can you jump into the
ceiling friend oh god you're in the room
what did you do I'm in the ceiling fan
ha ha you rule you're like floating on
the bin talal this game on this game
flawless Balki half love it oh man ha
I'm Eddie
can I interest you in a bucket perhaps
put me to put the bucket on my head
ok Wow Wow
Oh buddy ha ha ha ha do that again I
want to fly I don't know how I did it
you went inside it oh uh I wanna see if
we can get me up there that would be
amazing
go go oh oh go whoa whoa okay we know
how to do it that we'd unlock the
secrets of the game ha ha ha
see a daddy should be able to pick up
his baby uh yeah that would pretty much
sell the whole game wouldn't it yeah
just pick me up and take put me in the
sink yeah ok ok here we go
the sink what the [ __ ] so you're gonna
try to babies stack wash my little baby
but ok alright sit still please
it seems like whenever I start jumping
or something around physical objects its
Wow
oh it's cold you you did it get it get
it I'm proud of you were saying you're
proud of your son I'm gonna sink daddy
watch me yeah yeah sure you're gonna be
soaking your your face is so creepy your
face is so creepy
hi Daddy
[ __ ] your radio okay alright radio okay
going this step oh oh you lock the stove
I turned on the stove yeah I did it oh
okay I'm cooking my baby cooking a baby
we're right we're really low in food in
this family have you ever wondered roast
baby no it tastes good right it smells
like me hot as hell we clearly like
unlock your glasses daddy anyway and
mommy must have come home oh god the
baby is creepy oh you haven't seen it oh
yeah damn it you got to see it as a baby
I we got to make this work somehow I'm
riding my son to victory son to suite
deffence this life is not worth living
trust me your mom is Sonny bad you
should kill himself I found a hammer now
oh no no Timmy Timmy you do not want a
hammer
why can I break with the hammer maybe
the glass I think there's a glass table
over here that you can interact with oh
I did it could a maybe cut each glass oh
the glass ha ha I hate the glass became
green yeah
septic baby ok I hit rematch you're the
baby yeah and I am the baby because it
doesn't work Oh starting 3 2 1 and then
it's gonna go black I'm not destined to
be a baby this game won't accept it that
means they can check out our different
videos and get a different perspective
oh yes go watch Felix's video butchie's
PewDiePie on youtube if you didn't know
ok are we quitting here yeah I think so